el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski ha denunciado la existencia de
una trama en su país que estaba
preparando un golpe de estado para el
próximo 1 de diciembre detrás de esa
trama estarían representantes de rusia y
también el principal oligarca de el país
rinat akhmetov según selenski su
gobierno tiene en su poder audios en los
que se escucha a representantes rusos y
ucranianos sobre un posible cambio en la
persona que está dirigiendo ahora mismo
en el país valdímir selenski ha
aprovechado una comparecencia delante de
periodistas ucranianos y extranjeros
para asegurar que este intento de golpe
de estado no puede tener éxito que no
tiene ninguna intención de abandonar el
país y ha advertido a renata method que
no siga adelante y que no intente entrar
en una guerra contra su propio país